hi I'm Benedict but you can call me Big
Ben I'm somewhere over 30 if you're
feeling a bit strange the doctor will
see you now
and now you guys are you band up this
John how much do you love me
yeah I think you're pretty good good
I'm actually a huge Martin Freeman fan
for years and years yeah so I'm very
excited to be on the show thank you and
I'm very excited about the new Sherlock
season but my name is my baby yeah yeah
it's all about bond I didn't get a
chance to tell you what a big fan I am
of yours oh thanks you very much wow
that's a bit of a moment thank you guys
Sherlock Holmes amazing
[Applause]
I can Ratana I'm going looks like he's
never seen a baby before like with the
mystery he can't solve and that would be
absolutely right yeah because Sherlock
is not the world's greatest touchy-feely
person so I think yeah the fact that
this baby has come into the picture is
yeah pretty baffling for Sherlock I
don't think this the wrong way but you
look slightly like the new family in
Albert Square very very quickly
people still comparing you to an otter
there's new ones have you seen the new
ones this is an Internet so here's
Benedict right maybe we think that's
just a boy doesn't look like an officer
yes he does look at it just he strikes a
pose he strikes a thoughtful pose you
gotta think otters don't think that much
and yet they do they do they've got you
compared to another woodland creature
hmm Jim do you know what's coming no I
know you don't follow me on the Internet
can you guess what woodland creature
Martin Freeman might be careful it's
really unlikely
shrimp in the ones
no it is it's a hedgehog and you kind of
think how could a person look like a dog
because a hedgehog is not expressive I'm
so wrong so here's here's Martin here's
Martin you got a big head child couldn't
an end up like that it just couldn't
look like that we found this picture we
found this picture of an ox you look at
this okay look at this now we needed the
face of it you've never seen a happier
creature on planet Earth look how happy
this holler is with his new teddy bear
like the press
given to a mammal I sent out the command
I picked up my phone and I went will
need a big teddy bear now however the
big the word big is quite relative yeah
they've gone with a really enormous
teddy bear
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but it's it's just there's something I
don't know there's something about it
makes me want to kind of do
[Applause]
don't keep it there think of Mike Keota
[Applause]
more coming for you I don't know how if
you're an expert beatbox this is true
this is really impressive that's why I
found poco this is this is an you look
like in my head yeah eg in the house was
a recent film yeah we're getting old in
fact it was 12 years ago
yeah 12 years ago so if fresh-faced it's
actually more than 12 years we filmed it
15 years ago in 2001 Wow
Ricky Ricky it's gonna be late from the
class
do you do lots of people are you one of
those actors no yeah yeah but I mean I
think I think I think a lot of us yeah
don't we I mean it's either music or
it's or it's it's it's voices or tons of
voices I mean you know I used to muck
around with dictaphones at school for
ages and just you know do
interpretations impersonations of people
and great characters and it's it's just
sort of having any air it's part of what
we do I guess I mean even if it's not a
real person just to imitate or have
empathy with a state or a human being of
any general he was doing - back at
during the clip what I'm with the two
back of being just natural Watchers
that's one of my favorite 'back a moment
is just that take you back to be back
explain dispatch this is odd of all the
questions we had the one that came up
most often was Benedict to say the word
penguin what is this about well I
probably I got it wrong repeatedly in
the documentary it wasn't a documentary
about said animal it was a documentary
about I think about the South Pacific in
general and now I'm completely terrified
of the words don't go near what I know
here's the thing I thought for sure
they're making it up but we actually
look documentaries are both strange
islands the first one you sort of get
away with and then after that you lose
all sense listen carefully and the last
thing you might expect to see here
his penguins these are Fiordland crested
penguins named after this corner of
South New Zealand so why are these
Woodlands so attractive to penguins a
freshwater stream through the forest
makes a handy highway for a parent
penguin heading home from a fishing trip
the funny thing is you know you don't do
this in isolation you have a you have a
team of Natural History experts based in
Bristol funded by you the taxpayer it's
not just me sitting there at a booth
going I think I know how to say penguin
I say penguins
you
[Music]